both Swami's Amin I am so very very
grateful to be here and even more
grateful for the finally the Academy
waving the Jena Rowland's flag high and
saying all to all of us here is the
example here is the standard this is the
quality of work we should all strive for
take a look at what real achievement
looks like here is work that has made a
difference that is worthy that is
important there are many types of
Hollywood stars these days but to me the
most powerful and the most beneficial to
all of us is the rare star whose talent
and authenticity is so potent that their
contribution is synonymous with the
evolution of film jenna Rowland's is the
actress who smashed and destroyed the
female stereotype of her time her work
declares you want to see a modern woman
here is a modern woman you want to see
thought and heart and psychology and
conflict and life come feast let me show
you the consequences of love and the
loss of love let me show you ferocity
and grace combined look how powerful and
beautiful complex humanity can be let me
take you by the hand to places where you
have never been but that reside in all
of us you want to see skill prepare
yourselves and throughout her working
life this has all been done with grace
and kindness and a generosity that
befits a muse of legendary proportion
like her idol betty davis jenna is a
legend a true legend a legend for all
the right reasons and in addition there
is her beauty a ravishing deep beauty
that has been her keen ambassador to the
rich turmoil she can weave on screen by
falling in love with her on sight
you follow her wherever she leads it can
be harrowing and dangerous but
ultimately liberating and deeply
satisfying I was lucky enough to work
with Jenna in 2000 on a television movie
called wild iris Durrett
by the great dan Petry you can can you
imagine how excited I was to spend time
and act with Jenna Rowland's it was a
transformative time for me I watched
this great actress work with an
effortlessness that took my breath away
air circulates around Jenna in the most
refreshing way it almost ionizes the
entire set the atmosphere feels open and
creative and honest and she invites you
to jump in and splash about and discover
what you didn't know existed
between scenes we would cluster together
on our set chairs Jenna myself and her
wonderful husband Bob amongst the cables
and the dust and the plastic milk
cartons of gels and we would sit there
very much like my southern relatives sit
on their front porch relaxed and serene
Jenna was always gently observing and
curious about the activity taking place
around her we talked and swap stories
and I felt like the luckiest person
alive
being around Jenna is restorative she
confirms what you know to be true about
good work and she inspires you to bring
your own uniqueness to the party I am a
bit of an introvert by nature especially
after a long day on a set and I tend to
disappear into whatever hotel room I'm
staying in at the time but Jenna and Bob
cajoled and convinced me to join them
for dinners wonderful fun dinners where
she taught me how to eat oysters and
would tell delicious dirty jokes and
while one and while I don't remember the
details of one in particular I do
remember that it was particularly
debauched and it was a joke regarding a
parrot in male genitalia
it literally threw me into a spit-take
of red wine when I was first nominated
for you can count on me I was living in
a New York City apartment without a
television the morning the nominations
were announced I was dead asleep the
phone rang and in a confused haze I
heard Jenna's voice say well
congratulations I got the news from her
it is a memory I cherish and one that
still causes me to shake my head and
disbelief because I believe that without
Jenna and the road that she cut for us
the work of actresses like Meryl Streep
Cate Blanchett Julianne Moore Jennifer
Lawrence and many others worldwide
simply would not exist the impact that
Jenna and John Cassavetes have had on
writers directors actors and producers
has been seismic they shook everyone up
by showing us what was possible and
broke down the door to independent film
shortly
shortly after we wrapped wild iris a
beautiful red kimono arrived at my door
it was a gift from Jenna which I wear
backstage to this day I keep hoping that
if it drapes my skin for long enough
some of her magical powers will seep in
it also serves as a nightly reminder to
shake off fear stay connected and to
keep growing so Jenna thank you thank
you for giving us all so much of
yourself and for pointing us all
especially this actress in the right
direction